you know there's takes where everybody
on the on the set would be dying oh oh
my god kevin how'd you do it and i would
look at cube and he would just be
staring and i'm like hey man uh you need
to laugh everybody else is having a good
time he's like normally let's just get
the work done
he's the work done
good job partner bring it in
i remember one time he told me i said
hey man i just want to know for me you
know why don't you laugh why don't you
break when everybody else breaks he's
like because i don't want to waste tape
what
what you don't wanna you don't wanna
waste tape like but he said it with a
straight face it walked away as if i
should go oh yeah yeah
i don't know let's go
everybody cute one three one two three
haha [ __ ] you thought i was juggling we
out here doing promo q tell me doing
promo promo [ __ ] promo [ __ ] total cute
promo [ __ ] promo [ __ ] tell him to get
cute you know what we doing ah but you
tell him it's better when you tell me
sometimes i gotta promo [ __ ] but you
have an irish name
do i it couldn't be more irish has no
one told you that till now you know i
think my mother just liked the name
let me educate you something black
people
black people are notorious for picking
things that they saw one day and say
that's my baby name
uh me you know i'm following
the footsteps of of like a tom cruise
you know guys that tom cruise jackie
chan we're all cut from the same cloth i
know yeah i could see that fire i know
get that
analogy you tom cruise
probably the next mission impossible
yeah like stuff like that like hanging
off the plane for him to be all right
something like tom cruise is efficient
yeah like
you've always seen yourself as an action
star action star man i can flip
uh i did i did my own
nah he didn't want to do one stunt i did
i did one
which one i did the one i parallel
parked that car by myself
and uh there was one scene where i fall
out and i hit my head what are you what
are you talking about like you was in
there doing back-to-back stunts you
didn't do any stunts cute i did all my
stuff you didn't miss that mr triple x
himself backed out let me tell you what
what what old used to be action mode did
he came out tough no no no put the stunt
guys to the side i got it he did one
stunt threw him up against that wall a
little too hard didn't they the next
take cue was in that chair sipping
coffee i said
i said i said
what you doing man they doing a stunt
they hurt my back on the first one
[Laughter]
i mean you want to just hold on a second
there we go i just want to make sure
that you don't fall back and hit your
soft spot man if you don't get your hand
off my [ __ ] head i am i hear a man
of short stature that does not mean i'm
a baby
hey huh huh huh
how many kids on that
hey just tell me how many keys
let me see it man
we go
you know what i'm saying what you think
about
crayons all over the dresses cause i
like to draw you know what i'm saying
just little bitty
baby
here's the number one rule in hollywood
don't work with no animals don't work
with no [ __ ] kids i agree i did are
we there yet and they're 10 times more
professional than this one you got you
know what you've got another thing
coming
i don't know if we could do that
how far would you go to impress your
girlfriend's family i wouldn't go too
far uh you know my thing is if i impress
her you gotta go talk to your family
that's a great answer uh i really would
go
i probably would go uh
a lot further than he would because i'm
actually a nice guy
and i was raised to make someone feel
comfortable being someone's mother a
father but those gang bangers
uh that's your answer you know we're
raised differently that sounds like a
long long drawn out it's not a
journalist i don't think it's just i'm
just a polite guy hi you're her mother
oh my god i'm so happy to meet you
you're you must be her dad hi sir and i
will have a title
can we do roles with us uh
over here in the uk
i sway
but that's only if it's a good day
i'm with my man cube and we do what we
do we in the movie ride along i suggest
you see it too
oh drop it down
bars
bars
bars
you're funny oh funny um
guy walks into a bar
i'm hilarious would you ever consider
collaborating together oh yeah
what
oh yeah rapping and joking what is not
what you mean rapping and rapping no no
collaborations no collaborations unless
we collaborate at the end of the day it
makes you contemplate oh my god what am
i thinking i'm stinking but i'm wrong
come along with me on this ride alone oh
stop me long don't ride
long don't rhyme with long hater hit fun
police
lady gaga almost trips and falls to her
death backstage at an awards show after
saving her life
does kevin a
quietly accept your thanks and humbly
not tell anyone
b go on ellen and tell the whole world c
send lady gaga a bill
uh
go on ellen and tell everybody to hope
it go on ellen just be you don't think
you'd be humble and just like you know
matter of fact he wouldn't even wait to
go on him he snapped
the whole thing
as he go down he probably pushed him
he's saving her he snaps
right now
when you guys first met did you like
each other what was the dynamic like we
did not like i didn't like because no he
was actually playing basketball against
each other that's how you guys celebrity
basketball league i didn't like the fact
that cube shorts didn't fit correctly
like i don't like it when guys wear
basketball or shorts and they bunch you
all up
yeah his little
little jingle bells just hanging out his
and nobody wants to see that
would you rather
a british accent
in the ghetto of compton
or
it's funny already isn't it
would it not work
or an indian accent in the ghetto of
compton
there's a choice and we're getting this
and are we getting the one to pronounce
and we say things like
that
then i'm going to go with the india i'm
going to take the indian accent because
that guy when he gets crazy it can be
scary okay it could be real scary when
indian dudes get mad in the hood okay
i'm going to shoot it up no
that could get crazy and i think it is
hard for america to imagine you guys
with your kids when they were younger
reading
dr seuss in bed but did those moments
exist like what did that look like
i definitely i was a reader be a reader
i whip my kids and make them go to bed
they okay
sleep all right
nine o'clock or i just drug them with
like diamond tap yeah oh that's a good
one you know uh you put that in a dress
and put that extra tuscan in your
bedroom
[Music]
admitted that when he started working
with you it was love at first sight yeah
you had trouble saying the word love
back to kevin yeah you've done some work
on this uh i still can't get it out
come on love a face like that you got to
be a mother to love a face like that
just turn to him do people want to hear
you say it
uh kevin i shut up no let's say
kevin it's for the sam
i love you look at that
i love you
i love
you guess what that's your question
right now
take his hand come on man it's like it's
like it's like a come on it's like best
friends
i don't understand it's tough love it's
lovely you love him there's so much love
in this guy so much love
look at that face right there look at
this emotion look at that
yeah look at that that's his teeth
that's a love face man it's all love
here i love you too cute
you cube you won but i have gifts for
both of you that's right give me your
name
brother no
participation gift brother might need to
say to the champ brother we get the
gifts you're nothing but a low down
carpetbagging scallywag people think me
and mike got this rivalry because on
twitter we always go back and forth with
the snapping and stuff like that yeah we
go with the tweet the tweet wars so
people misconstrue that for us beefing
but it's no beef at all man all love he
actually told me that he was excited to
see the movie and he can't wait to see
it and wish me well man so he told me
something totally different he told me
when i catch kevin you said i hope this
is a bomb i'm gonna get kevin as two
pieces of surprise when i catch you
break him off something